um Margaret it
saying you were a dominatrix yes at one
point yes I'm not a good one though
because I am I'm so passive
do you mind if I choke you yeah I don't
really have an opinion about it and also
I don't find it sexy yeah like so I I
was really poor at um you know doing it
and being effusive about things you know
what they want I think is a you know
just mostly to get in their head and try
to figure out what they you know want
from you but I never was I don't know
intuitive enough or could get into that
space I did a little bit better later so
like not that long ago before the
pandemic I was doing um classes in
Japanese rope bondage so that was
helpful oh Japanese have their own
version well the yeah with the rope
bondage and like to try to you know make
these um really beautiful kind of knots
and stuff that you know I think is
almost like sculpt sure it's like a very
like macrame almost it's really
beautiful so that was really inspiring
well you put the ropes on the on a body
on a body and like like this yeah well
different poses and different ways like
different ways too holy [__] that's
beautiful Bobby like that in the room by
himself stuck I just they keep me from
chewing tobacco
until your Cravings go away it's one of
those like I don't think I'll be able to
get out it's like one of those Chinese
fingers well this is actually really
pretty yeah it is pretty yeah yeah it's
cool so I think that um you know I did
get better at that and um you know it's
just uh I just also don't really find it
sexy so that's part of it like the
person that does it well is somebody
that is turned on by the act of doing it
and I never really understood why it's
sexy I just couldn't find that in me but
I like the aesthetic but the guy that
you're doing a two is it a guy or Grano
is a girl oh so you're doing she's
probably getting off on it you wish she
was like also we were uh both trying to
learn she was just trying to help me and
then
um you know and that was really great so
we had a really good time together but I
don't think it was sexually motivated it
was more just like crafts
does it Color Me Mine or going to you
you know some kind of like a crochet
thing yeah yeah it was more like hey I
got this I finally got this down so that
was more than that yeah yeah huh so was
it what was it a class it was a class
yeah there's arts and crafts and
[Music]
um we had an amazing teacher who is um
her name is mistress Midori and she's
the uh preeminent Japanese bondage
Master Miss dress master in um this
hemisphere so she's an incredible
incredible source of information but um
we couldn't go to class dominatrix I
understand but the people that are the
what do you call it submissive the
submissive I just never got that part I
don't think really
well I mean wait hang on look at me
really what do you mean interesting I
feel like our entire sexual Dynamic was
that of you being a sub tied up dude you
never tied me up though we played
role-playing where I was like shy
I'm the shy guy but it's like it was
just the role I was like Brandon the
Virgin I played Jimmy and Brandon yeah
yeah so I but I was never like who never
John the alpha because when I see that
it's always like you know I mean a black
mask and like this and they're just
getting whipped to death I mean I've
never done that
well that's more like
um yeah that's the turn on is just
allowing somebody else to take control
um but yeah I as in that world there's
all these different variations on the
theme and I've seen some really strange
stuff that I didn't understand like how
is that sexual like it got so far away
where this one guy who was like in a
vacuum bed and they took out like sort
of vacuum sealed him so he was like a
like a steak
[Laughter]
yeah
but then then he was really turned on
and he [__] in the vacuums and then it
was like he was with he was marinated in
his own sauce
and I was like it's not really sexy to
me I guess but he was really into it and
I was just I couldn't really figure out
why this was interesting but I I was
happy to just be there you know like
okay that's great
um that's
okay wonderful that's wonderful you know
you are really enjoying this moment yeah
and
um I I think that's that's great you
know people have different Kinks and why
they do things I just didn't really
quite get the entry pointed
um there was one guy who really wanted
to set my leg on fire and why he would
do that with uh
um
hand sanitizer so spreading leg on my
leg with hand sanitizer and then light
it and then I would just look at it and
go okay well then it was on fire for a
second and then it was out and I did not
understand why it was sexy yeah but it's
you know it's fine wow wow that's his
thing that's his thing and then so then
he and I I we broke up but then he was
dating this woman who really liked to be
in a motorhome in the small closet in a
motor home had to be motorhome yeah it
had to be like the really those are so
small the narrow closets and she would
just wedge her body in there and just be
in there and that was like her whole
thing she just wanted to be in the for
how long
um like for 10 minutes or something and
she would get off on that yeah
I feel like that's something you you
like being in super tight tight spaces
yeah I like it but not sexually
but then I can't move my arms to jerk
off there's no way but maybe it's like
her impetus was not openly sexual but
it's just like a comfortable feeling of
oh wow kind of like in the same way that
um I like vaginas you know I'm old
school like you know how
um came up with that whole system to
um to humanely
um humanely
um kill cows to kind of um take away the
stimulus they would feel more corralled
and their body would be pressed on and
they would have weight on them